what is up there reject nation we are
going to watch the next episode of what
if so excited check this out because
let's see that we got ultron returning
baby guys before we go into that i do
want to say a couple of things really
quick first off if you end up enjoying
our video please go ahead and hit that
like button it's hard work and the
effort pays off thank you subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the
finale of what it is up huge thank you
to everyone who has followed us over at
our patreon page during this time i'll
cover a bunch over there but what i
really want to do right now is shout out
to channel called dos cavazos guys if
you haven't seen their channel they're a
wonderful couple do wonderful reactions
don't personally know them but i've seen
plenty of their videos they cover what
if as well recently started up squid
game go follow them check them out after
you're done watching our video today
they probably had theirs up before ours
anyway also got a shout out the the farm
fan what the hell is the name of that
company pray for dave why don't i keep
going today fraper
you guys are thank you team for editing
on the highlights let's do this
we've seen this before a universe in the
final days of destruction
but this particular story this one
breaks my heart
oh poor watcher
here they come we got 90 seconds start
the clock
damn does sound like her
yeah right lake bell's a great match
awesome please dude
you guys road in here
[Music]
nice headshot
yo
cloak of invisibility
yeah dude he does over there hell yeah
hell yeah
oh
awesome wow i'll clear down below 18
seconds clint clint
oh his winter soldier arm no
clintor soldier
[Applause]
yes
way to go so you really think the secret
to taking down ultron is here it's
russia hawkeye
ultron required one thing an organic
body to call his own one that fused the
powers of man machine and mind
into one
god
with the infinite power of the mind
stone ultron began to lay waste to the
planet oh damn
you don't have to do this i made you for
peace it's evolution only a primitive
mind would fail to see
he's got the james spader voice
tony dies again i've done a lot of that
this series he's done all these things
he's killing him
i wonder if marvel's bitter
it's like the end of terminator 3
but the age of ultron was only beginning
oh
[Music]
another theme of this series is the
thanos vision the whole time could have
just done that
oh
there are worlds beyond my own
worlds that needs
me
oh man you can just create them like
that holy crap
to every corner of the universe holy
crap
damn ultra this is the age of ultron
this is the dawning of the age
no
oh
true destruction
[Music]
just in case you wanted to see every
corner of the universe thoroughly
destroyed
oh
god
is that real thorough party thor
no it's kind of marvel
seen the killer robot movie and i gotta
say i really don't think it needs a
sequel
biter finger
oh
my god
damn that's a hell of a shot this is
gonna blow this planet
up
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
wow how are hawkeye and blackwood
five units
how are they gonna do anything about it
he's done
i am bored now
at last
the realization nearly broke the machine
with his mission complete ultron was now
just a program without a purpose the
victor without a war sentenced to spend
all of eternity
who said that yes
ultron ascended to a previously
unattainable level of consciousness he
became aware
of them
see you
our universe is beyond my own
oh
what the hell is this oh damn he even
swore
oh
buddy
even i cannot imagine the horrors that
might follow i am [ __ ] bricks right
now
no
no
even that machine is not as invincible
as it might think there is still hope
for this universe
welcome to the kgb archives have you
ever seen raiders
that's what i was thinking
so
where do we start
pick a box
this is lurking over here watchers like
hurry up guys
oh my god watch her get involved come on
man help at the research
or at least nudge the right box off the
shelves
hey
claire this is my color hey don't try to
make this fun nat
my will to live meter is flatlining okay
and the last episode was way too
humorous you're so close
[Laughter]
i can show them i can intervene i could
save the multiverse and so many many
lives
and get credit for it look the answer
is right there
yes
uh yes
this is pointless wait
what
watcher should have a reaction shot
come on man
he's already taken over every program on
the planet yes yes every digital program
the one that i have in mind is a little
more analog
grab it grab it no
way
you did it
what let's just say you're gonna feel
like a real jerk for almost quitting
wait stop it that you found it
that was my box
there's still hope
[Music]
they need to be silenced you do not have
to do this
but it's my purpose tony stark what have
you created oh
the end of everything
hydra kept here to supervise the russian
super soldier program
oh this is the basin civil war okay
gotcha gotcha
yeah let's get the code face going
dr strangelove
so our only option is to upload you via
a sentry drone you will not be the first
genocide
[Music]
yeah
it's like aliens yeah dude
oh you're crawling all over the walls
hey
they are pretty badass in this episode
wow nice
[Laughter]
your team
this is way more intense than the
zombies episode yeah
okay
whoa
the ultron hype mind appears to be out
of range
that door's not gonna hold we gotta move
[Music]
i feel like i'm watching chris redfield
and joe valley
this is a perfect call this is just like
an umbrella academy like a lab or
something
bio monsters
oh
cool
no
clint
oh now she saves him yeah
clint
oh no way they're totally reversing this
i don't want to fight anymore
buddy you got an ultra on your side dude
come on
clint
oh what a badass
dude
that's right the ultrons can't move
whoa wow
what a beautiful shot
oh
yeah
let's go faster
[Music]
why weren't you able to connect to the
hives it does not appear to be within
the observable universe then where is it
what universe
what
piece of space-time fabric reality
[Music]
oh
it's like watching yoda fight palpatine
i don't understand this should not be
possible
oh but anything is possible in a
multiverse
literally
literally broke the fourth one
and the fifth sixth seventh and eighth
walls too
wow
space jam
all that suffering and you i just
exert my will watched the natural order
of things i cannot intervene
baby all i do is intervene i will bring
peace it is my purpose
[Music]
come on watcher
come on who want to
[Music]
yo
or the power of my right hook
oh my god
oh my god what is this doing to each of
these realities
what craziness
oh my god
whoa
isn't this more fun than just watching
and to be honest it's a lot less creepy
on your part
the creeper
damn
oh damn
whoa
i didn't evolve by staying inside the
lines
run
watch it doesn't matter
from here
i can see everything oh
jesus
that is nuts
[Music]
no way did this end
oh okay oh my god
see him up into strange i am so about to
get loose this is a strange yeah yeah
yeah
i'm out of options that thing has left
me no choice
are you ready to break your oath
yeah you want me to say it oh yeah oh
yeah want to hear you saying okay
i see now
i need your help
yes
yes oh
oh what a cool cliffhanger although i
didn't say better to come ratchet's name
in the opening credits yeah way to hold
on to the surprise yeah
okay yeah there it is i'm sorry better
dude nice it's like oh yeah also didn't
want a spooky guy to start
but dude that was that was freaking cool
yeah that was really cool this whole
time vision all i had to do
just light some of the stuff instead of
wanda
i didn't realize i had so much firepower
i could have just lasered him in half
you know sometimes the obvious choice
doesn't come directly to mind you know
what can you do he's got all the
internet in his brain that was a lot
more of the hawkeye i've been wanting
felt very much had a mad fraction run
in more ways than one
matter of fact it kind of feels like a
tease of the kind of chemistry he might
have with with uh yeah with uh
oh my god oh my god hold on hold on
who's gonna get to it first really
steinbeck who's gonna get the what is
wrong kate bishop yeah
don't worry it's an alley-oop yeah
no no i i've been saying this name
repeatedly for weeks now but i literally
just read the comic i'm like what the
hell
okay okay we eventually got there and
that's what saves the credibility
and dr strange seemed like he was doing
all right yeah you know he seems like
he's adjusted to this little you know
bejeweled hell world that he's sentenced
himself to pretty well i thought when we
saw him he's going to look all like
stressed out and weary man
but you see him he's like no welcome to
my quarters how are you doing yeah
develop your third eye while you're here
that was uh that was cool that was
really cool
this is truly how you're seeing the the
creators teach that it would you'd see
that there would there is an overarching
narrative and that it would all tie
together and this episode is the one
that makes it the clearest because yeah
it has the cliffhanger of last one and
then now you're seeing like okay the
explanation for that cliffhanger versus
how a lot of them have sort of gone
which was like oh i want to see that
episode of that
you're not gonna get that and here they
actually follow through on that
and uh they make freaking um
iago
uh a great character i know it's not
iago who want to
hey man can you imagine if gilbert
gottfried was narrating this universe
this is great they could they haven't
confirmed it's uatu yet right even
though let's look at the credits even in
the credits it says the watch watcher
yeah but the main
thesis out there yeah theory would be
that most every time someone names him
i've never heard any other watcher name
attributed to him right right and that
was cool to see him get involved and he
they really gave him a little bit more
of a colorful personality yeah i was
surprised i thought they would still
keep him like
kind of stoic yeah and philosophical and
heavy everything he kind of just becomes
a dude at some point
just go over the what the hell are you
doing
come on man it's right in front of your
face what are you doing yeah being an
idiot
that's the thing is is i guess you know
at a certain point uh you know it's
outside of his uh realm of normality you
know he's thrown off guard and even even
somebody with as removed of a position
from time and space as he has you know
as much omnipresence as he has access to
when you thrust him outside his comfort
zone he's just a dude like anybody else
what's cool about how the mcu i think
can often handle
some projects that were considered a
little bit short of hitting the mark
things like how thor the dark world
seemed to really pay off with
uh avengers end game or how you know
even with the mandarin how that really
pays off with shang qi
and there's just a couple of examples
this
is making an age of ultron suddenly
really pay off right that's much more
worth it
because a lot of the common joke too
of age of ultron was like it's not an
age it's like
it's a day
an afternoon
right 72 hours of ultron
it was this is like literally the the
age of ultron bigger than that not just
the age it's literally him showing his
singularity dominance across all time
space and reality of ultron yeah it was
spooky it was cool you know and uh part
of ultron's i would like to kind of get
a better sense for like
the ultron goal a little bit because
what kind of threw me for a loop
was um how ultron after he like
literally vanquishes all the planets
we've been to
and then
you know they had that shot over like
it's lonely at the top uh
that moment where he's like reflecting
and feeling just
isolated and kind of empty
suddenly he hears about something and
he's like destroyed yeah like i got a
new goal oh just a moment ago i thought
you were coming and after you started
coming to the realization as this
artificial intelligence that you're a
little bit more emotional than you might
have realized you are no he's just
waiting for that next prime directive
yeah i think there's nothing to destroy
anymore i've destroyed it all i brought
peace peace is boring boring the pursuit
of peace by destruction however
yeah yeah so uh i mean it's not really a
big deal because i'm like no he's doing
the ultron thing what he's programmed uh
what what he believes
his
his understanding of his program of his
objective to be so yeah it's almost like
the black the the the uh killmonger
episode in that way some people kind of
griped that it's just like him but to
the fullest extent there's not like some
kind of diversion from the character
it's more just like what if they were
uninhibited in achieving their ultimate
goal you know well yeah i mean i i feel
like with the killmonger one though he
does
just do a more
extreme version of what he did
accomplish in
the movie you know and doesn't
ultimately lose in the end whereas this
is like this is like no this is this is
what they feared
what ultron could ultimately be this is
worse you know fear and it is it is cool
to see that realized in this show uh
that they really are taking advantage of
that and especially with the animated
medium like my favorite episodes are are
the ones where i really feel like
they're doing
something that i can't really see the
the live action movies doing although i
could see a live action version and then
i i take that back actually yeah this is
a longer this could this could have been
the age of old trump it's a certain
extent but you gotta build up the
multiverse and everything but i loved
how direct they were about it like they
were like practically explaining the
rules you know yeah
and uh
showing like the veil that uatu lives
behind i love that i mean yeah just kind
of getting even just a bit of a visual
and a sensory idea of what his realm of
existence is like because they've done
these frequent animation flourishes even
like when he's talking to doctor strange
in that one episode you know he appears
through and then fades back in this very
fluid motion to being a silhouette
behind the fractals of the you know
crystal that he's trapped in but it
seems like that's kind of the nature of
the universe is these different fractals
and things
and sorry no yeah i just i loved that so
much of this like i guess you know
people have been speculating about like
when's he gonna jump in when's the
watcher gonna get involved but i loved
that it was more about like you know
ultron finding him and spending time
with them you know really in his turf
you know watchers territory and that
alone gave it a really kind of expansive
and and fresh feel
while also having like the best hawkeye
and natasha's story like possible that
was my personal favorite i think they
outdid what we got in the movies
[Music]
i really enjoyed seeing that i really
cared about them i love the
uh dystopian
world they're inhabiting as he's like
wore these human warriors last surviving
warriors yeah you know like i mean
they're not the the only ones obviously
but they are essentially less surviving
i thought the the visuals they brought
to life
especially like how they did the role
reversal of
hawkeye being like go in the end but i
love how badass he is where he like
turns around with his boot like i got
you one left
yeah and it has one of those you know i
thought of like those beautiful epic
shots from the tomorrow war yeah that's
what i thought of it yeah yeah
especially towards the end you know
they're all climbing and it did have
that like sci-fi horror vibe to it
i mean sure every
pretty much all these with the doctor
strange ones are was the only one that i
wish had just a few more minutes it's
like it would have been cool to have the
like the one beat that was sort of
missing for me was natasha grieving over
the loss of clint yeah that really felt
for their bond here well i could i could
feel is funny cause the second zola pops
back over and is like we gotta get going
i was like yes i could feel the plot
having to kick right back in for a
minute yeah and yeah it's funny because
because it's two it's not even it's i
mean lake bell does a great job in these
i think but it's it's it's almost kind
of
it's funny to me that yes such a great
back and forth between these two
characters actually isn't carried out
even by scarlett johansson and that was
something that thinking about like the
black widow movie i was like damn you
know i would have loved to have seen her
and and jeremy renner bounce off each
other in
a way kind of akin to this but i am glad
that we got it at least for those
characters yeah and uh
uh getting to show these the sides of
his power i think what they really
demonstrated here especially were the
conflict of of uh choice comes in with
ultron and him really shows that watu
has ultimate power and he could it's
like that's kind of that's where i keep
want to say vision that's where ultron
has that that like that baffled
attitude of like
this is ridiculous
you can
you can do so much more and you just
stand by
you're just a
benchwarmer watch people's lives that's
it what are you doing
come on man
party
make some peace or silence at all or
something jeez some of the rules of the
watu or not really the rule the
narration with him
uh what exactly how does it work because
it seems like he narrates in the like a
book like past tense he's not reading
like a script which is present tense
right he's not saying like ultron moves
to this planet he would say he would be
like
he wouldn't say like ultron stands on
top of this planet he would say
and there ultron then stood on top of
the like he talks in past tense like a
narrator but then so is it like is is
the way the watcher is because is it all
pulled into the immediate moment
and then
he's then he's um
you know okay is he then pulled into the
immediate moment
or does he know how it's supposed to
play out and he's narrating and then it
doesn't go according to how he believes
it's supposed to play out
what i took from it is that usually
really just uh i'm being quite pedantic
about this whole thing
it's fun to chat these things around
what i've taken from this over time is
that yeah it's like given his his
abilities and given you know his
his place among time in reality he's
able to kind of peer in on moments that
are always happening so to me it is kind
of like yeah looking in on a book where
you've read it already it is in the past
tense
even though it's always happening
because of time and space and all that
and then this one kind of brings him
into a present where he can't even
really narrate anymore because i've
heard that question too about like who's
he narrating to is he narrating to us
because here you know then they bring
you know it's like ultron can hear it so
clearly who want to is talking to
someone yeah uh you know if if another
character with sentience is able to pick
that up himself he could be but you know
it's like why would you need to just do
all this out loud and and why would you
need to like share your feelings about
it he's alone he's bored because he's
always like well this story is
particularly a sad story you guys i
don't know so really what you're saying
is if we watch you just kept this
[ __ ] mouth shut no that's what
happened yeah
start this show he didn't feel the need
to bring begin a podcast based on his
experiences as an all of time and space
multiverse watcher that is what happened
i mean like ultra wanted to pierce the
veil yeah if he just didn't say it she
was like who is talking yeah and i love
the way they animated that because from
the second it started i was like he
hears him but at the same time they did
it in a way where it still looks like
he's kind of just having character
thoughts
um but yeah that would to me almost read
like a moment that's become very popular
lately but you know it's directly to me
hearken to like loki where it's like oh
oh we're i don't know what happens now
we're we're in the sort of realm of new
events and that's what i took this to be
as is uatu is kind of being thrown out
of the continuity he's aware of so now
the book has been turned into a script
basically by your metaphor i like that i
i think it's
makes this the stakes actually feel real
100 yeah cause i love that kickoff point
and coming over from last episode him
being like what what is this and then
him starting up a news story like
nothing happened and then being like
wait a minute hold on how why why are
you even here
why did you get in the booth with me
yeah yeah yeah like it's it for a show
that has you know been an anthology up
until this point with this loose wrap
around that really did make it feel a
lot more vital and a lot more like oh
man they're shattering through these
different worlds and stuff like this
could be causing all kinds of havoc
right now in ways we can't even imagine
and they're fighting you know i kind of
wish the zombie episode had a little bit
more of a tone like this like this this
is like fast paced yeah exciting but
there does seem to be a real like
dominating terror and there's like a
dread too it's not not like deliberate
but there is a dread
tone uh towards it just because of the
amount of apocalyptic mayhem that's
happening but i i enjoyed it quite a bit
i thought this episode in particular was
what's up no no no let's see the
thoughts see them go on and see the
thought bubbles it's an interesting
contrast and i think that this one is
helped along by the fact that it is like
bigger in a lot of ways than the other
episodes because it really clinches a
serialized thing whereas the zombies one
i feel like something that can hamper
some of the previous episodes is that
they do feel so contained and i think
it's because they throw you right into
it at the beginning of this one where
it's like lived in right away and then
we go back to see how it happened that
narration versus the the other one
starts off like you know bruce banner
launching it but yeah other than
spending so long
for us personally because i know a lot
of people really love that episode um
and that's not to i don't want that to
overshadow our enthusiasm for this one
because yeah everyone was great and here
was nice to hear toby jones back ross
marquan does a really good ultron um
you're like yeah i mean i i didn't hear
about james spader coming back so it was
cool yeah because then off iron man
again
marvel gets killed that made a half of
the internet happy yeah
everybody who's been upset about marvel
getting too woke will point to this
episode as their favorite forever i wish
i wish ultron just killed everyone who
just and then marvel just shows up and
just come one bunch
yeah yeah hey but at least she showed up
right away in this one no one had to
call her this
is the type of thing she's always away
dealing with so at least there's that i
got it and then i gotta say though man
like the way uh thanos got taken out
like that
um
that's the other theme of this season is
is in a lot of universes thanos ain't
[ __ ]
yeah man like that actually really
uncuts
i i it's like funny and i was kind of i
was surprised
but i i gotta admit though too i'm like
i kind of uncut some of infinity unless
there's some detail i am completely not
factoring in
like i don't know vision not taking a
life or some [ __ ] um or is there
something different with the power level
of the vision then
that just killed thanos versus the
vision and infinity if there's something
i'm forgetting is it being all right
union of the ultron form with division
skin and all that or i don't know i
don't know i know the vision was a
little weak in infinity war he was
injured that's why they took him to
wakanda and ever but he still had stuff
he still had the mind stone in there
yeah and he's used that before in other
situations so i'm like is there a clear
explanation that's totally i don't know
why he just didn't laser him in half
yeah because that does seem like a bit
of a plot hole retro actively speaking
it makes it go like wow infinity wasn't
peter quill's fault
yeah yeah
mission you've been holding that [ __ ]
and all you got to do it's a little
bling
what what's wrong with you man no no
needed to dust it or anything like that
yeah well he knew because we needed
phase four to happen yeah yeah the movie
has to happen
all right guys well that was a fun ass
episode thank you guys so much for being
here what did you think about it what
was your favorite moment to leave your
thoughts down below uh go ahead and
subscribe got one more episode to go
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
video if you didn't go ahead and hit the
dislike button but thanks for sticking
around to get to this part of the video
as a committed committed hater there
also uh hey uh we got some patrons to
shout out i want to say a thank you to
for uh pledging to a special tear
sean long dawn academy award oscar your
name is oscar the jedi bros before hoes
simply
hello to peter pacheco joanna meet me
and saint louis
matthew bling men sing rogue creed
taking a pee sj94 banging all the best
justin fartin martin miss waters or
should i say kayla i want a nail yet i
can't do it
[Laughter]
rosie baity o'donnell darth yoda or so
you you know your name ruby the doobie
dynamite cal durian the centurion
pinnacles i'm falling for colin philip j
smith
jr a jed
smith melanie griffith leblanc happily
natalie never boring doran chase my face
harder the gardener you've addressed the
cova
[Laughter]
thank you guys so much for being here
you guys rock your support means more
than you realize thank you so much
hopefully uh we see you guys still
sticking around the uh
stay good keep it classy
ultra the ultra pain
[Music]